- [Instructor] A gym that
specializes in weight loss
offers its members an optional dietary
program for an extra fee.
To study the effectiveness
of the dietary program,
a manager at the gym takes a
random sample of 50 members
who participate in the dietary program
and 50 members who don't.
The manager finds that
those who participated
in the dietary program, on average,
lost significantly more weight
than those who didn't participate
in the program in the past three months.
The manager concludes
that the dietary program
caused the increased weight loss
for the gym members
during that time period.
So pause this video, and
see, and think about whether
you think the manager is
making a valid conclusion
based on this study.
Alright, so let's first
just make sure we understand
what the manager is concluding.
The manager is saying that
there is a causal relationship
between the dietary program,
that being on the dietary program
causes increased weight loss.
And they would be able
to make this conclusion
if it's a well designed
experimental study.
And you might say, well what does
an experimental study look like?
Well in an experimental study
you have a control group
that wouldn't have the dietary program,
and then you would have a
treatment or experimental group
that does have the dietary program.
And then you would see, hey if these folks
are actually seeing more weight loss,
and if it's statistically significant
then maybe you can conclude
the causal relationship
that the dietary program
is causing the weight loss.
And this kind of looks like
that, until you think about
how folks were assigned
to either of these groups.
It would be a well
designed experimental study
if you took random samples
from the broader population,
so you took a random sample,
so that's our random sample
from the broader population.
And then from this group
you randomly assigned folks
to either the control or the treatment.
So you're randomly assigning,
and then the people
who happened to be in the treatment group,
not the people who chose to be in it.
Well those people, you'd say,
you need to be on this diet
and you make sure that
they are on that diet.
And then if you see a
statistically significant
increased weight loss then you might
be able to make this conclusion.
But that's not what happened over here.
In this situation, we
didn't randomly select
from the broader population
and then randomly assign
folks to these groups.
What happened is people
self selected into either
being in the dietary program,
or not being in the dietary program.
I'll say, not the dietary program.
And then what they did is
that they randomly sampled
from the dietary program to put them in,
I guess you could say the treatment group
and then they randomly sampled
from this control group.
And so in this situation
you have a significant
confounding variable, people
essentially self selected
themselves into the dietary program group.
And that you could view
as a confounding variable,
and so it doesn't allow you
to make this causal connection
because people who selected themselves
into the dietary program,
maybe they're more
motivated to lose weight.
Maybe they can afford the money
and that wealth association
is associated with being
able to eat better,
and maybe being able to lose more weight.
Now a conclusion that the
manager might be able to make
based on this study is that
there is an association
between participating
in the dietary program
and weight loss, but once again
you can't establish the causality.